feminism is one of the biggest scams  they're indoctrinating young girls I was  even indoctrinated to think that your  career is going to bring you happiness  then you hit 40s 50s not married no  children and it's heartbreaking or not  happy and I'm so happy and so grateful  that I figured this out in my early 20s  you have some women in their 30s 40s  listening to cardi B dedicating their  lives to their career and they're going  to be miserable they're creating a  certain lifestyle for themselves and no  man is ever going to want them then we  start hating on men because men prefer  younger women well that's not really  men's fault is it it's society's fault  Society should have told Girls when they  were much younger than at that age  they're going to be most desirable but  no they were busy building their careers  and building all these different things  which Unfortunately they wake up one day  and realize just isn't satisfying enough  and so I think it's very sad